the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is my definition including the
method to paint the car so to change its
color and the question says you create a
car with this line here so you're
initializing it with 4 comma 2 what's a
line of code that changes the color from
whatever it initially is to read the
first one car dot paint red is sort of
attempting to do the the way that we saw
on the right in the slides where you're
calling the class name dot but it's
missing the self so we don't know what
object to call it on so that one's out
of the running the second one is closer
but we have red here as a variable as
opposed to a string so that one's not
not going to work
the third one looks good and the fourth
one is just weird I don't think that one
will work it's attempting to put a value
for self but you've already called my
car dot instead of the instead of the
class class name dot so here this isn't
going to work so since you already
called the object named dot method name
you just have to give it the other
parameter that it needs which is the
color I think the majority have gotten
it right